we don't see that often crowder misses  the three  james stolen by payne james gets it back  caruso  up to james for the slam what a wild  play  and the lakers go back up by four  crowd up top bridges an open look that  three-pointer is good and it's back to a  one-point game  i loved how phoenix ran it right back  quick question is that an assist when  you throw it off the backboard  james has it in his tank russo doesn't  make this play  a couple of weeks ago but he trusts that  lebron james has the ability  the athleticism and the help to go get  it off the backboard  absolutely beautiful turning back time  like a runaway train i'm not giving up  the deuce if i'm caruso  i'm always in a contract here  good unselfishness by alex